welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
today we are speaking with sachin kundu
sachin is a senior software engineer at
microsoft and he was one of my
colleagues when i worked at microsoft
we went down the rabbit hole on
programming languages on software
engineering
on machine learning reinforcement
learning and also
what makes an excellent software
engineer and what makes an excellent
tech lead
anyway i really hope you enjoyed the
episode today remember to like
comment and subscribe and we'll see you
back
next week i'm just uh on the bridge of
the the star trek enterprise at the
moment
oh emphasize yeah
i'm floating i'm floating in a higher
plane above the above the galactic core
right well at least somebody needs to be
on earth so i'm holding the fort
while you guys are there so who's your
favorite star trek captain
you're going to hate me for saying this
but it's janeway yeah
oh i knew that you and i would match
mine is january 2. oh brilliant
yeah you are you're in the standard
domain
because few people choose janeway but i
think for me she has been the best
captain
her choices are always i see herself as
a captain that's why
i did voyager was probably one of my
favorite series
i don't know i've never really thought
about ranking them precisely but
it's awesome had so many of some of the
coolest
episodes like that one where the uh the
dinosaurs the earth
and then became this advanced sort of
nomadic space
civilization and they just beam the
entire ship into their like
cargo bay that was far away that was
amazing they have
really different concepts and i really
like that series and as a person i think
jane vivo's as i said like a captain i
could serve
under her i've always felt like that she
was so real and her decisions were
sometimes she had to take hard decisions
and it was very nice like
really good captain i feel yeah yeah i
don't disagree i i just think
picard was uh pretty cool i liked his
sort of
i liked his eccentricities t earl grey
hot he's
pissed off if the temperature is like
one degree c
where from where it's supposed to be and
sometimes just goes off with some
shakespeare or whatever
right yeah the card is cool that's the
first word which comes to my
head if i have to think of picard it
would be like he's cool
there was also a scene where some bad
guys beamed onto the bridge
and i remember picard like runs at one
of them and throws this sort of elbow to
his head and i thought
and he does it just instantaneously like
the guys show up and he's just boom
jumps in to try and knock him out i
thought nice
get his hands dirty
is the brother hello
what do you think of my new appearance
i i can't see you oh i think
because of the sunglasses maybe oh now
oh
nice what's up man we're we're brothers
now
peas in a pod blues brothers
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
with me tim scarf my two compadres mit
dr keith duggar yannick lightspeed
kiltshare
and today our very special guest sachin
kundu
now i worked a lot with sachin at
microsoft he's living in finland at the
moment he's a senior software engineer
he's been
there for about the last four years or
so sachin has done so much stuff he set
up a distributed systems meet up in
helsinki i think he's just set up a
meeting
uh now around robotics his interests are
reinforcement learning and robotics and
machine learning
software engineering distributed systems
large-scale data
engineering and so when i interviewed to
be a software engineer at microsoft
sachin was on my interview panel and he
was a complete
he was a complete bastard he asked me he
said tim
name five research papers that you've
recently read and tell me about them in
detail
and he completely put me on the spot i
was absolutely scared out of my
wits but the really cool thing about
sachin is that he's one of these guys
that always wants to be the best version
of himself he's always studying he's
always learning new things
and like just his energy is really
inspirational for me which is why
i thought i'd invite him on the show so
sachin welcome and thank you so much for
joining us
thank you i'm always surprised when you
say about the interview it was supposed
to be pleasurable
and i hope you felt like that because as
you might know in microsoft whenever we
take an interview
the interviewee should always leave oh
it was fun it might be difficult
it should still be fun and i hope it was
like that for you and if it was not
my sincere apologies
yeah it was fun he was just curious like
hey
what have you been reading and uh tell
me about it he just wanted to see what
i have to say so so you did set up this
meetup and when i went and checked out
your linkedin
it's the first linkedin i've ever seen
where somebody has the phrase flame war
and i thought this is awesome like he's
saying i set up this meetup so people
won't
flame war but right actually you know
that now i'm inspired
people get caught up in like very minor
things instead of discussing
more serious topics like so that's right
yeah people get very religious about
certain technologies
or technology stacks or programming
languages or whatnot there can be a lot
of religion
associated with it identity yeah
for having fun in an interview when i'm
here like i have
almost made up my mind i always talk to
your favorite programming language
just to you know heat things up like oh
everybody has that oh this programming
language i like this one and then you
can go into
uh discussion i never do that when i
start the interview but always at the
end when i
everything is gone through just to have
fun with the candidate it's always
what's your favorite programming
language so what was tim's answer
what was your answer tim that's a good
question
the thing was for some reason i was
completely blindsided by the question
and my mind went blank and all i could
do was um go back to
the kind of stuff i was researching on
my phd and that was all about
there was a guy called jonathan foote
who was doing analysis of music using
self-similarity matrices
and he had this concept of the kind of
um a kernel function which
when you created this sliding
self-similarity function it they had
this kind of exponentially weighted
gaussian which would
prioritize things that were in the
recent past versus the long-distance
relationship
and that was the thing that came to my
mind at the time but i felt quite
um annoyed with myself afterwards
because there were many other things
that i could have
said why don't we do a round robin of
everybody's favorite programming
languages so let's start off
with the heat instead
favorite programming language for a long
time it was
uh c-list or common lisp but i then
realized that
not many people are using it and
especially in the industry like by fair
and very few people who would go
with common list i find it's very
intuitive and easy to
write but lately i started to write
haskell more pascal right now it would
be ascap
i think it's quite a nice language and
it forces you to think in
the terms like types very strongly
combine that with the functional
has completely or purely functional
i think it's opening my eyes to write
better programs so that's why these days
i write haskell quite a lot interesting
i'm inclined to say python but actually
i think it's javascript
and i'm serious it's become it used to
be this nuisance but it's become
i think a beautiful language in the last
five years or so with es6
and uh i i just love the fact that
it's in browsers it's you know you can
write servers with it with node
you can write scripts with it and so on
it's
i generally tend to use also in
frameworks just whatever
fits best at the moment but overall
yeah python and javascript are
i feel i'm not a big type fan like
and this is especially in deep learning
people are like well i need a typed
language whatever and then
deep learning stuff and what's the type
of this tensor
oh gee thank you i feel this focus on
types it only makes sense in very
specific
narrow contexts where a type is really
informative but i find often
types and class names and so on are
are are very non-informative and just
having a data type very often does not
encapsulate really the enough
information because what you want to say
is for example this is a tensor
that has x many rgb
images which are the output of this
layer
and so on but none of this is
encapsulated in the type tensor
could i yeah anders helzberg was a big
inspiration for me and
of course he went on to to create
typescript but i i cut my teeth in the
world of c
sharp and i could see firsthand the
benefits of having a statically typed
language just in terms of tooling and
compile time error checking and testing
and so on and
this is a language where you can a
priory explicitly define the kind of
objects that you're working with it
doesn't surprise me at all that a deep
learning practitioner who's working on
esoteric
geometric and manifold spaces wouldn't
want to exactly
quantify the type of types that they're
working on yeah
and let me say this if types are like
violence if they don't solve your
problem it's because you're not using
enough of it
so i think like this complaint you had
about types what i would say is you
should look into some of the tuple type
sort of structures and literatures
because for example
if i have a tensor and whatever let's
say it however many dimensions it has it
doesn't matter if i can just describe
that as
look this is a a tuple type where it has
these types for each of the columns
or that sort of thing then it becomes a
genericized
type system if you will and also there's
been a lot of effort put into kind of
automatic typing so you have to do a lot
less
a kind of work to get the type system to
do what you want so
this is why this is one of the reasons
actually why c plus is my
my favorite language because it's it's a
super pragmatic language
it's multi-paradigm you can do
object-oriented program if you want you
can do
even functional program to a large
degree if you want to
and you can do meta programming and it
although i'll admit like it was a pretty
ugly syntactic with some choices that
were made there nevertheless
you can do it and it's always had this
great emphasis on
on typing on don't pay for features that
you don't use
on just a very pragmatic kind of
approach to programming you said
you should embrace types yannick like uh
i'm not because
okay so now you you have i know you have
the covariance
operator inside pi and that by
definition gives you
a symmetric positive like a positive
semi-definite matrix
as an output like this is just something
that no
type system in the world i guess you
could make like in java you can make an
interface and slap that on
and so on but it's still the fact is
we all just have to know in our head
that what comes in here
is positive semi-definite and therefore
we can do things with it
and it's these types of things that i
think types
don't encapsulate could we link this to
the symbolic thing
so we're doing kind of continuous
geometric programming
which seems to be almost antithetical to
symbolic
uh reasoning which we have types for but
before we get to that let me just
address something i just said there so
actually type systems
alexander was it alexander yeah
alexander stepanov
who is the person who created the first
template library
in class and was really one of the
driving minds behind
the idea of templates and uh type
type parameterization and whatnot
believe it or not
what you just mentioned was exactly his
goal in cr
in creating these systems was the
ability for example to say
that this algorithm within the type
system
is quadratic time complexity
logarithmic space complexity etc so that
you would have
these traits these type traits that you
could build into the type system
so that the type system itself could do
a bunch of advanced kind of reasoning
and make selections automatically as to
the best algorithms
so like for example positive
semi-definite would be a type trait
that should be associated with that type
and then it actually allows
a lot of powerful automatic kind of re
reasoning i don't need to say resting
like evaluation whatever you want to
call it reasoning's a
hot word on this podcast error but the
point was to
to provide this nuance so that you could
have a very powerful type system
we're not quite there yet it's under
development a lot of times the syntax is
quite ugly and whatnot
but in concept i'm going to come back to
what i said earlier if types aren't
solving our problems because we're not
doing enough of it
but anyway i think in haskell there is
one special thing about the types and
especially when i was saying i like this
thing about types is that
you can think of all types generally in
every language we have and type
that is you add to a data type to extend
it so you are ending them
but in haskell uh you can or a type like
uh something can be dish
all this and that leads to quite
intuitive programs that's what i was
saying
it's opening my mind how to write better
software which is guaranteed to be
correct because it's like provably
correct
that's another thing i like about the
types but it's provably correct once it
compiles you are quite certain about
uh the mathematical provability of your
components and you can pour them not
just and them
and that's a that i find that in very
few languages
that ability is there which is quite
special so that's why i suggest like
try types not just for the sake of data
types like
this is an int and you're passing it in
which is a good one but also
thinking in types which is what haskell
asks you to do
think in types and in immutable data
structures
i think that's quite intuitive like i
like it
do you think there's a trade-off between
the kind of expressiveness of a language
and its usefulness i mean
i know some folks at microsoft have said
this what i love about some of the
modern languages is there's been so much
cross-pollination
right because i started with javascript
as well when just like yannick i was
over the moon when some of the es6
features came in like things like
lambdas and object destructuring
i discovered functional programming
through c sharp when they
introduced integrated language query and
i think i was on the
i was on the beta in april of 2005 on
that and it just blew my mind
and i was always the annoying developer
who checked all of my code was written
using link queries
much to the chagrin of other people on
my team
but it's quite difficult to use these
traditional functional programming
languages in production
i think it's difficult because we are
like most of the
universities like people just do some
scheme to do some artificial basic
artificial intelligence course and then
never touch
a functional programming language again
so i feel like the easiness or difficult
is just because people just don't have
enough experience and they just don't
spend enough time with functional
languages haskell in particular is known
to be more difficult because it's quite
pure but there are easier languages and
what did i like like i started by saying
oh i like common lisp
and i'm saying listen from like 1960s
and almost
every language is asymptotically trying
to become
lisp like it's eventually going to
become or more look more likely
a lambda or functional closures or
something which we can't consider quite
good in new languages has been known
since
1960 when the lambda calculus and we
wrote like things around it and you can
actually prove everything that is
correct
every language is trying to eventually
become this at least that's how i think
wasn't that like paul graham or somebody
has graham's law or whatever which says
any sufficiently complex software system
implements a half-baked poorly thought
out a common list
machine or something like that yeah i
mean i know that uh and i haven't looked
at functional languages
and many years but for a while i was
interested in them and and i know
online a lot of the flame wars if you
will around this
centered on so the sort of more pure
functional languages that
just flat out deny the existence of time
there's no immutability there's no
change it's just everything has to be
this grand
functional definition of the world or
whatever and
and what happens in a lot of languages
and i'm going to actually include lisp
in this one is when you try to maintain
the sort of linguistic purity that
doesn't quite fit with the actual world
there's these friction points and these
impedances
and as much as people try to push back
and say
look like why can't we just add some
really simple way to do this
make some little crack in the armor here
if you try to keep that iron grip on it
it's like in
in star wars when princess leia tells
you know admiral uh grandma whoever or
maybe
i forget who she told the more you
tighten your grip the more systems slip
through your fingers
and that's what happens to these
languages whereas that's why i like the
languages that
have evolved pragmatically like c plus
where
if you've ever watched any kind of ted
talks or discussions
with strewstrip that kind of designer c
plus
he's just this he's this awesome uh
consensus builder like he's not
offensive at all like he's just out
there really trying to help people
achieve
more kind of in microsoft language and
find a system that works that can move
everybody forward
and sure you end up with a little craft
here and there but that's better than
the kind of
linguistic purity of some of these other
communities what was the drama with
python
recently the the original creator of
python has finally left the community
but only after many years of pushing
this one feature which he really wanted
to get in he finally got his way but it
broke him
was it the walrus yes i think there was
like a big discussion about the so far
for people who don't know the walrus
opera it's like this
period followed by an equal sign it
looks like
walrus with walrus whatever teeth horn
what is it called walrus
tusks yeah okay and what
what you can do is you can assign a
variable
as an expression and the return type of
the expression
will be the result like the variable
itself that you assigned so
you can evaluate some function save that
into a variable
check that value of that variable at the
same time
as you assign the variable so it used to
be that
an assignment in python i i'm not even
okay i'm not even sure about this but
an assignment itself had a value of
i'm not sure it depended on something
but here you can do
where previously you'd have to do
something like next
line in file equals read from the file
pointer
and then you check whether or not the
next line is zero or an empty buffer and
then you continue
you can do this in one and the it's it's
a neat feature
but i think the the worry was that
people are going to horribly abuse this
because you can write some
very extremely illegible
code like that looks nothing like python
by just abusing two or three of these
walruses
uh in conjunction with each other
yeah so i think there was a big fight
between the this is really useful crowd
and the
this goes against this mantra of python
that is better explicit than implicit
better
purity purity more simplicity than
complexness i i used to play squash
and it would really annoy me when i
would typically when i was playing older
guys that weren't
trained they weren't coached they would
play the game in a way that i hated
i loved to play it down the wall and it
was a beautiful game
and and it was just wonderfully
structured and
that's the same thing with programming
languages when you start thinking about
software engineering
what we want to have is standardization
we want people to be writing things in
the same way we want to be testing in
the same way
and that means that we're going to have
to force people to not use the language
in all of its expressive form even
regular expressions they're incredibly
expressive
but they're very difficult for people to
read and maintainability is super
important so what how do you square that
circle
in my opinion and i'm pretty sure this
is strauss actually coming back to him
is he made the point that when we design
systems what we should really focus on
is making the right thing
easy to do rather than focusing on
making the wrong thing
hard to do so in these systems like with
the walrus operators yeah but
somebody might go out there and do
something really nasty
and then our purity will be lost that's
the wrong focus like the focus should be
well if they're trying to do something
legitimate and they're doing it in a
really nasty way why don't we provide
some very easy
well-designed way for people to achieve
that
instead so less about trying to make
everybody do what you want
and instead making it easy and well
defined for people to do what they want
i want to interject i might be
completely wrong
in the the fact that the discussion was
about this
but that's just what i have what i've
gathered
so yeah i might be completely wrong in c
plus you can just say
auto x equals expression boom case
closed
value and type inferred for you
so so satchel and clearly you are huge
into software engineering this is your
bread and butter
clearly there is a dichotomy between
your academic and theoretical interest
in languages and of course that
feeds in or it informs the way that you
write software
at work but clearly there has to be a
separation between the two so
how does software engineering ruin your
theoretical interest in
programming languages no it shouldn't
i'll come back to what i was saying
before
it's that other software engineers or
the software engineering as a group
has been taught to use procedural and
object oriented languages more
and there is a there is an upward spiral
on it once you do it
there are more programs on it so you use
it it's just that
most people do not have enough exposure
or experience in functional programming
languages
and if they were then we could have used
how scale
and it would not be like you'll have to
think differently
or it is not as effective or productive
i don't think so
it's just that it takes a long time to
become productive and there is just not
enough
material to become productive or
opportunities to become productive
but on that your because you're making
the argument that it's essentially
socially constructed to some
extent but surely there's also another
argument which is there's something
about these functional languages
because you did you hinted that there's
a bit of a longer learning curve it's
hard it
it's harder to be productive with them
and also
it's much harder to understand because
these languages are much more compact
and it is harder to understand so it
does that trade off against the
maintainability of the code
no it's not it's like this it's like you
have a fiat punto imagine
it's easy to drive you can sit in it and
start driving instantly
and it works most of the time it can go
from one place to the other
but it's difficult to drive a ferrari
you
need a little bit more time to
understand how to drive it but it does
go at 300.
it's just that there is a difference
between instant productivity because
it's easier yes
uh function language is a little bit
more
hard to understand it's but it's also to
do with that we just don't get enough
exposure to do it but
sorry just on that quickly though
because i think some people would
i personally agree with your ferrari
analogy but i think a lot of people
would
resent that analogy and they would say
that you could do exactly the same
things with traditional languages
they're just not as expressive
uh yeah it's like stretching the analogy
very far
it's uh with a traditional language i
find it more difficult
to say it's provably correct
which i like about haskell in particular
or purely functional languages
like once you write it and it compiles
the way the type system is written you
can be quite certain that
it's referentially transparent you have
made the types in such a way
that they make sense and once it
compiles it works
this i find quite special no you can
still do the same stuff in probably
visual basic
if you're very careful programmer is
just easier
to do i think to make complex systems
work in functional languages once you
get
used to them they're getting used to
them it's a little bit more work
but just quickly on that i think that
you can express
quite dynamic systems in a very small
amount of code using functional
programming but
some software systems are huge and we
had this whole object-oriented
programming revolution which has
informed much of the paradigm of
software engineering today so again do
you think that
those paradigms are incompatible with
each other and do you are you a believer
in object oriented programming
i think object-oriented programming does
have its usage
uh i i feel like all the systems if
personally given
to me a choice i would write all
central core which has nothing to do
with
io or not changing the state in the
world as much as with a functional
language i just find it
quite easy to say okay it works
but object-oriented programming paradigm
is not
it's not bad you can design very good
business systems with it
again going back to these things i was
saying it's just that in object-oriented
languages
types can be extended only with and
which does lead to some design
hierarchies which are not very
compatible and then you have to make all
of these
changes in your hierarchical structure
just to fit
what the language expects because there
is no way to say it can be this or that
so you'll have to extract something out
in the base and the base
probably is very general it just needs
to
yeah i don't think that's actually true
sage and i think like at least in the c
plus land we have lots of meta
programming capabilities to express
union types intersection types etc so i
think it's that may be
a language restriction to me one of the
fundamental differences between
functional programming and other forms
of programming has always been
immutability
has that changed is immutability still a
core defining feature of functional
programming languages
i would say so i would say so and and i
would say that
specifically talking about haskell which
is not necessarily limited but
functional i'm also saying that haskell
has a special type system
there are many languages functional
languages which
don't have that kind of a type system so
functional languages in itself i think
yes it's because of the immutability
which lets you write referentially
transparent code
uh it makes a lot of sense to have this
provable characteristics
but high scale in particular since it i
i've not written that much
especially not in the meta way if it
does support that kind of types i think
you can similarly do the same thing
okay so if we get to this if we agree
that immutability
is one of the core differences if you
will
the kind of mental impedance that so
many people have
with with functional programming
languages is that the world is mutable
at least everything in our experience
tells us that what we see around us
is is mutable now maybe you're like a b
theory of time person and you think that
the passage of time is an illusion and
and all past and future here and but so
functional programming forces you to
think in these weird
versions of time it's almost like
everything around us tells us there's
one universe
but instead if we start to believe in
like the multiverse
type theory and i'm like the literal not
just regions of a larger space but i
mean like a multiverse
in this in the sense of many parallel
branching time
what not you just twist yourself a notch
trying to avoid the very
simple perception that you have of
reality and i think that's the the
disconnect between functional
programming and a lot of the problems
that people
everyday people are just trying to solve
with software
now i think in the functional
programming language we always said that
you always write the central core
and then you always have to write some i
o monad so you can actually change the
state
is just that if you separate the i o in
a separate layer
you can very strongly reason about your
core which is where your business logic
lives and then you can
let the state change through a very
specific
a layer and it reduces the mistakes
you could make having said that i think
you can very
write very good systems with any
programming language
it's just a person-to-person maybe
it makes them think more productively
and i do feel that every programmer
should
understand one object oriented and one
functional language quite well because
it makes you realize
how to write better programs in both
without going into flame wars
if you choose that object oriented is
the only way or function is the only way
you're still leaving something on the
table to become a better software
engineer a better programmer because
yeah you can learn things from one to
the other and get the ideas
so that i'm going to totally agree with
which is why i'm such a big fan of
multi-paradigm
languages because i like it when a
language allows me to think in many
different ways
clearly like for example just putting
constraints in a database which is a
functional
definition right that there's this
foreign key relationship between these
two tables or whatever
extremely powerful concepts and so
multi-paradigm for me is where it's at
and and this analogy
c plus is like a a used car dealership
where you can like show up and and just
buy or rent or lease like whatever
vehicle
appropriate for the the trip that you're
about to take
and and sometimes what you want isn't
actually on the lot but out back there's
this old
car factory and you can go back there
and get a customized vehicle built for
you
like in a few weeks could i just gently
chat i mean i know i'm laboring the
point a little bit here but
i i agree that having multiple paradigms
is a good thing and certainly it means
that if you're searching through
the space of problems and you want to
find an effective solution quickly
it helps you but again from a software
engineering point of view
technical debt and maintainability and
having a homogeneous
technical set of solutions is actually
better in many ways
so you said as well by the way that
learning functional programming
languages might help you in something
like python
python is a multi-paradigm language so i
suppose it would be quite easy to use
those functional paradigms in python but
even in python i used to use a library
called pipe
by julian pallard and that allowed you
to write python
a little bit like you would c-sharp link
queries and i would concatenate all of
these kind of functional c-sharp like
queries in python
i would check it into the repo and now
i'm checking in code which looks nothing
like any other python code
and some people might use the ita tools
some people might use
list comprehensions and so on so you can
see that what we're doing here is we're
creating a very different types of
python code
is that a good thing
oh yeah as long as the team is
productive
and you have made good choices it's a
good thing most of the time other people
read your code so if it's a good thing
from an organizational perspective it
will always be whether the software is
maintainable
over 10 years you know imagine so not
only for you but for the others then
it's good
the question i think is the programming
language the correct place to build in
opinions on on how to write software
right because it is easy
if i have to choose between a framework
being over opinionated
such that it stifles me and a lot of
things i want to do and i have to
almost often in like frameworks i used
to have this with you know keras back in
the day it's like okay
super easy to train a cnn but now i want
to like
access to this gradient and do whatever
with it and if that's
becomes or it's become easier but so if
i have to choose between over and
under opinionated i'm always going to
choose under opinionated and i feel
in a thing that is as general as a
programming language
if it's not for a very niche audience
i i feel the to to give the option to
do whatever you want and then maybe
within a company you can say okay
people we're just not going to use later
tools
maybe that's the better approach than
the other way around
where the language itself is so
opinionated that it doesn't let you do
things
more productively there's three things
in a company when you look at the
strategy of software engineering there's
technology there's process and there's
people so we want to
develop people that are highly capable
in software engineering
we want to develop some process which
gives us consistent ways of working so
it might be
we only use pi torch or we do this type
of testing or
we have to use ci cd and all of this
stuff and what we're doing is we're
conformalizing
because it gives us more predictability
it reduces technical debt and so on
now i don't know i don't know how it
works at microsoft anymore but
do you do this at the project level as a
tech lead do you say okay guys
you're going to use pi torture you're
not going to do this you're going to do
that
but because you can't possibly do this
at the company level because most
companies
are like a conglomeration of different
business units and it's siloed and you
couldn't possibly get everyone to work
the same way right
that's absolutely right so i'll keep my
personal so when we start a project it's
always what is the customer using and we
try to use as much of fair because it's
difficult to convince somebody to change
it in the short period
of time we work with them otherwise we
have a working agreement again yes
uh things like these do go into or what
are we going to do
even what kind of linting standard are
they you'll be surprised how many people
have a problem with
what linting standard you're going to
use this is completely stupid but well
it's true
so you have to agree to that we need to
make sure that you
uh have a working agreement this is what
we are going to do
and this is what we are not going to do
and of course then there is a strong pr
process
to get stuff in and if uh
and if somebody makes something which is
not following the working agreement you
make changes
but yeah microsoft level i don't think
it exists in other companies which i
have worked and we had like thousands of
distributed services running
every team as you can imagine working on
their own technology stack
and just abstracted away from the api
so how how bazel said that teams can't
talk to each other
now what i mean what he meant was like
you cannot exchange private information
among the teams
we are only behind the api and behind
the api
some people were doing go some people
were writing things in like pascal some
whatever
we don't even know it was all api
abstracted and how they manage their own
system
was their own problem but they were the
ones who had to maintain the
uptime of their api so they were on paul
for that
i wanted to come back to something
yannick was talking about i think we got
two lines of
of inquiry here and and yannick really
hit it on that head is the programming
language the
the correct place to constrain what
people are working on
and the problem with doing it at the
programming language is
it's bloody hard to predict the future
and the future needs and if you bake
into your programming language for
example
we shall not allow operator overloading
like
you may find out at some point in the
future like that was a bad idea
so i remember again i started off as a c
programmer
fortran went to c plus and at some point
in the mid 90s or whenever
i decided to give java a try because it
because running a browser
and everybody loved it and it was the
next great thing or whatever
so i learned it and i started trying to
write scientific code
in java and boy oh boy did i feel like i
was wearing a straight jacket because
suppose you're writing a linear algebra
equation or something
and plus if you had operators overloaded
nicely let's say a runge-kutta algorithm
looks exactly the same for one dimension
as it does for multi-dimensions because
you just overload multiplication
times et cetera and the natural ways to
be matrix
multiplication and addition in a java
library it would be something like
x dot multiply parentheses y and you
could never know if it was lowercase m
or capital m or maybe it was molt for
this library and multiply for that one
it was just this mess
right because they had this religious
you know prohibition against
operator overloading and you fast
forward years and years and now
java i think i'm pretty sure it's added
operator overloading to some extent
they've added in the equivalent of
templates i.e like type parameterization
which they were against in the beginning
they didn't they don't they didn't i
think it's diff
oh maybe this is really new but they had
this thing called
what was it called it was called
different and
it was just at the compiler level so
what it would do is you could define a
template variable which at the compile
time
while you're developing would act as the
type like you could make a list of
vectors
but then the byte code would still say
object
which is why in java you can never or
you couldn't at the time i was doing it
you could never do
new t if t was your template variable
you could never do that and that just if
you have to write like meta programming
that's the crappiest thing ever because
you always do
if object and then if float if bite if
in
if long
that's no good so my point is you can't
predict the future so try
like strawstrip said focus on making
the right thing easy to do and build
libraries if you want people to do
some particular form of coding build a
library that supports that activity
and the other thing that this opens up
is it allows darwinian
evolution to take place and for people
to have the flexibility to develop new
things
i get it there are there are trade-offs
right i always say there's no silver
bullets
things are going to come at a cost i
think it was socrates that said
nothing vast enters the human experience
without a curse
so i get it there are costs to this but
i think the benefits outweigh that when
we make languages that are more general
and flexible
and multi-paradigm so you can always
write it dsl
so that's your language is expressive
you can always write your nature
on top of it and let people which was
the cool thing about lisp
yeah that's exactly the thing about
lists that i brought up earlier yeah
right
so i wanted to come to in general the
question of software engineering and its
intersection with machine learning
because i am a total noob
beyond research i write research code
and the goal there is just to get my
final plot
like whatever i have to do to make that
is i
i have five versions of my ipython
notebook and my scripts and so on
i just don't care and all i need to do
is get that plot and maybe
modify that a bit what is your
all of yours maybe his experiences with
machine learning like what's important
it seems is the language an important
thing
or is the the process an important thing
is the
infrastructure an important thing
because
yeah i don't know what does it let's say
someone has a machine learning
idea for a product what is something
that they should
pay attention to when pulling up that
product and deploying it and
delivering it great question station
i could talk forever on this side please
exactly exactly so you know having
worked or shipped
many different machine learning products
out there so it's
there is a discrete there are two
discrete areas one is the discovery
where you are making the model it looks
completely different
from once the model has been developed
so the there is almost no software
engineering
when you are doing the research portion
of it and
people are doing all kind of stuff and
trying different things out but as soon
as
the model is done and there might be
very different iterations when the model
is improved
but that's part of software engineering
and then i think most of the time like
way more time goes into the deployment
or getting this stuff out than it does
for the research portion of it
and that's my own experience that there
is a small team which is doing a lot of
research and they are trying all kind of
ipython notebooks and whatnot
at some point they say okay we have a
notebook published
we have a model published and now we
need to get it out
and that takes a long time that takes a
really long time to get the stuff in and
that's
a lot of software engineering portion of
it so what is like the
the most what do you feel people may not
realize
where the biggest time sinks in this
process
first of all writing a good inference
architecture like
uh you have a model it's going to use
some machines to
run the interest like the model is done
so you have to write all of these
front-end servers which are going to
accept your api then there'll be api
gateway on top of it there'll be some
database which is stored in the result
you'll have to send all the logs in like
machine learning portion model is a
really small portion because it's all
developed and it takes a long time
between the model being developed and
actually being used by the people and
then when you fit in the retrain portion
of it okay we're going to collect the
data
in actual usage we'll come back and try
to improve the model over time
that adds more complexity and don't
realize how much time i think it takes
five times or four times more work to
get this thing running than it is to
develop the initial model it's not true
maybe the initial model comes
from some other research area and there
are lots of overlapping researches so
i'm not counting that time
you're working in a particular aspect
but i'm not counting like the
research with pending to resnet because
we're starting from resnet we'll forget
about that we are starting from some
problem
but have to solve that problem and to
get that into deployment takes
very different timelines i've got a
couple of thoughts about this i think
machine learning
is uniquely problematic even software
engineering is really hard because a lot
of software engineering is
problematic but that's a separate
discussion but because clearly a lot of
software engineering is about
orchestrating the non-interactive phase
of deployments but
i've also noticed that when people work
in the tech industry they are unaware
of how multi-disciplinary most software
engineers are because the bigger
even earlier when we were talking about
people process and and tech
people from the tech industry tend to be
very good and
these are folks that can be writing the
code and they can also be
productionizing it and maintaining it
and looking at it culturally i see
quite a few different axes now the first
thing with machine learning projects is
they've got one foot in the analytical
world and one for in the operational
world so you need to know all about
the modern data warehouse and how to
build data engineering pipelines and so
on
you need to know all about machine
learning itself interactively as a data
scientist
and then there's a complete cultural
dichotomy between data science and
software engineers
and i used to think that we should try
and homogenize that you know
those two things together but we can't
because if you're a hardcore data
scientist
you care about ablation studies and
writing papers and so on
and we can try as much as possible to
make you a software engineer but it's
just not going to happen
you're just and the other cultural
dichotomy is between
data scientist folks and security and
governance type thinking
because quite often these folks are not
thinking about unintended consequences
of their models
and how the models get validated and in
an engineering context is completely
different to a data science context
and how these things get governed in
production so the tldr here
is that in this life cycle there are so
many
different folks involved in the process
and you need to manage those handshakes
very carefully
let me jump in and say that so forbes
had a survey
uh i don't know a couple of years back
of
data scientists and data science and
whatnot and it said something like 80
of the week of the work was going into
data engineered
engineering data cleansing connecting
integration whatever
and this is really disappointing to to
this generation of data scientists that
came out of school and thought they were
just going to sit down and get plugged
into some
great clean data and deliver fantastic
insights and everybody
is going to be wow this look at these
insights so i think what you have to
just
look out for is that the engineering the
cleansing aspects all the stuff that
wraps around the brain
almost like in the human body actually
although most of our mass
is not our brain it's all the stuff
around our brain that makes us uh
integral part of the environment the
sensory apparatus and all that kind of
thing
that's where you're going to spend a lot
of work unless the team is structured
such that you're paired up with
data engineers and software engineers
and the workloads are divided in that
way
i will also just mention one other thing
there yannick which is this is just a
small thing that i've seen
bite so many data scientists when they
were doing the research
phase of things is make sure you
understand
lookahead bias because it comes up in
all kinds of weird ways so if you sample
if you divide up your data set
in the wrong way you're going to get
look ahead by it if you're not careful
about an index and you've got a plus one
error you're gonna get
look ahead bias and i can't tell you so
many times we've seen we found some
awesome model this is gonna just crush
everything
or make us millions of dollars and then
actually some
further down the road we find out oh
damn there was a look ahead bias
back to square one it's crazy and and
what do you feel with respect to
let's say end users of systems like this
because
the engineering is a whole one side of
it and okay
a lot of time goes into engineering and
deploying but then it's also a matter of
how does it actually benefit an end user
and how to end users
because we as we as researchers we often
feel like
whoa i'm like two percent better my
model is like two percent better i've
new state-of-the-art
i've won the gold medal i get to publish
a paper but then
it seems like a lot of times to the end
users they don't care if it's two
percent better
it's so what in your experience what's
kind of the what's
let's say you have a traditional system
that's based on just a couple of reg x's
or whatnot
and then you're trying to replace it
with a machine learn system that
does the same but supposedly better do
you find
users what's the biggest annoyance is it
i can imagine users being like
if it screws up once where the old
system didn't they're like
it screws up or is it i don't know
what's your experience with
end user acceptance of machine learned
systems
ultimately like an axiom for product
development if it's two percent better
there's no point doing it
if it's twenty percent it's no point
doing it should be two x
better to launch a new product there is
just absolutely no
uh it's so expensive to launch a product
that if it's not
2x better the machine learning is not
too much better than regex
now at least i wouldn't spend my time
and people
just don't get the benefit of it so
that's what i'm saying but you're
absolutely right i read this
article somewhere on media was written
by
this person and said she was complaining
that the academia is
other publishing of papers is so
like different from solving real world
problems yes
that she tried to submit the paper to
neuro ips and
she gets rejected and she's tried to
send a paper to like many different ones
which is more practical
and like solves an applied problem
but she gets rejected because it's like
oh it's for a very specific
use case and it's not general and it's
something like that for some reason and
it goes into that
a research is quite happy because they
have in abstract
and got some better two percent better
results but uh
an applied paper doesn't get through so
i i see that there's a huge amount of
difference but for the end user if it's
not 2x better
to some new problem which is in an
applied space
it doesn't make any difference so it's
like quite separate the academia world
and the actual
real world of shipping products i
completely agree with that sentiment
because
so for eight years or so i was i
defected to the dark side and i was an
evil wall street quant and high
frequency trader and things like that
and we're constantly consuming white
papers about
anything you know stat arb whatever we
can find and
in the ivory tower like many algorithms
are fantastic
trading algorithms or any other kind of
algorithm right
because they just ignore so many of the
the basic realities of systems like
transaction costs adversarial effects
market impact et cetera just
all kind of let's just all ignore all
this inconvenience stuff
and create this beautiful theory and
then as that collides with reality it
just shatters
and so there is this big disconnect
between what practitioners face
and the knowledge that's being developed
in academia that could actually help
those practitioners
i'd quite like to call out as well that
one of the issues we have is this kind
of myopic conception of
statistical and machine learning models
clearly we are too focused on accuracy
there's a real issue around metric
selection in general and again because
we're in this multi-disciplinary team
data scientists quite often don't really
know what metrics to
use and so many of these models the
whole reason not to use machine learning
is it produces so much technical debt in
production right it's basically a black
box and we are
instructing the machine through examples
rather than explicit instructions
and these these models they learn
shortcuts they overfit
they're biased and this myopic
obsession with accuracy is antithetical
to what we need to be doing we need to
be
trying to introspect how these models
behave but we also need to accept that
there's a limit to that introspection
and even the methods of introspection
are highly problematic
because basically as we said the other
day we're just using mathematics to
reason about mathematics and we're not
really getting anywhere
most of these introspection techniques
can't be done non-interactively in an
engineering
context and so again how do we draw all
of this together
and i frame that as a can i frame that
as a question actually and i'm just
going to frame this as a question
uh is that you get the confusion matrix
and what i've tried to do
in business development with machine
learning is really focus
with the customer on how do we take that
confusion matrix
and map it to a kpi like a business kpi
what's your roi going to be based on
this and you'll find that some of those
quadrants in that confusion matrix
may have much more of an impact like if
it's a predictive maintenance
scenario you don't want false positives
because then you send out crews to do
repairs that were
unnecessary or maybe in a different
context of a highly important
valuable machine you do actually you'd
prefer not to have false negatives
because if a turbine
over speeds it may destroy an entire
section of the factory so
yeah go ahead yannick sorry could i just
quickly interject because we were saying
yesterday that there's kenneth stanley's
conception that objectives are
a tyranny and that if you do have key
performance indicators there's this
notion that
to get from where we are now to where we
want to go we should have a
monotonically increasing metric between
the two
places and actually you need to get
worse before you go better
and it creates this kind of group thing
called convergent behavior and systems
which is
almost antithetical to what we want but
the counter argument and i find myself
saying this at work
i'm like a parrot i just say this oh we
need to be we need to be objective
driven we need to be an observable
organization we need to have
data scientists following key
performance indicators and we need to be
following this through the life cycle of
the project
if you say it enough times you almost
believe it
there's a bit of there is a bit of a
circular reasoning
in these papers that are like let's do
away with objective but at the end we'll
get better in that objective because
they they justify throwing away the
objective
by the fact that at the end they're
better at the objective so what they're
they're actually saying is just that
the the linear path might not be
the best one but you still you like
clearly you can't explore purely in all
directions and and
improve on every possible objective it's
like
at some point that cuts into the no free
lunch theorem and then yeah i agree
you should sit with the customer but
with respect to for example
explainability
like next time your windows computer
hang crashes like good luck
calling microsoft and be like why did
this happen
they're going to be like what what do i
like it's not like
application traditional programs are
necessarily explainable ml is is a good
thing but it's not
the one above above all so
yeah if we with respect to this 2x
better and so on
we see machine learning coming into
pretty much every single
field now all the people are trying to
apply machine learning between all the
fields and so on
but not everywhere are big improvements
to be had so where do you see in the
let's say in the near
or midterm future where do you see the
biggest
impacts on machine learning on actual
practical
end users like i've often said something
like gpt3 or eventually gpt4
will be like a giant breakthrough that
changes
a lot of industries but i'm not sure so
where do you see
where do you see maybe you're closer to
end users i don't know this is my
personal interest but where i would
like to see is machine learning applied
to
robotics so right now lots of robotics
is still
standard mechanical like closed loop
dynamical systems and there has been a
lot of promise around oh
reinforcement learning is going to solve
or we can apply reinforcement learning
to robotics and there's a lot of
stuff on simulation but probably if we
conveniently ignore all the real-world
effects of
moving something in the physical world
and that they don't really apply or if
there has not been great
advances not i mean maybe i don't know
of them but
that's what i would like to see like a
reinforcement learning or the promise of
reinforcement learning applied to
robotics i think that can make a
substantial
improvement to humankind if he could get
good
robots in because right now robotics is
quite primitive now should have
substantial
impact like gpg 3 for example or or
something better than that
can have a substantial impact on
human life you know we can make better
chatbots i don't know whatever
making some fake things there but i
think if he could
apply the problem what has been promised
for reinforcement learning in robotics
i'll be so happy
is there a fundamental kind of like
disconnect
between maybe the bit world and the real
world and the fact that machine learning
operates with
you know lots of data fails lots of
times during learning and so on and
maybe we just
can't afford this in the in the right
quote-unquote real world of of actual
physical robots and
do you think that has anything to do
with it or is it just that the problem
is harder
yeah i think it could be like a a lot of
reinforcement learning is happening in
the simulation
and you require quite detailed model to
be brought into the simulator to do it
and then you have to ignore things like
gear slipping or the actual friction
coefficient of the motor you're using
it's i think it's a hard problem but it
has been promised for a long time that
it should work
and i think lots of people are working
on it to be honest and i just wish that
one day we would be able to get to that
so there's this company in cambridge in
the uk
just doing autonomous cars and they're
using end-to-end reinforcement learning
to teach it
i think they're like okay we're going to
show the whole sequence of it and the
car should eventually learn how to drive
it something like that
i think if they could make it work that
would be quite interesting
use of machine learning for real
practical usage
and let me tell you two areas yannick
were where i am seeing
high value from machine learning and as
much as i bash
cnns and say that they don't work well
in a theoretical
kind of sense they work well enough for
a couple areas
uh and they're both remote monitoring so
it's basically
using either vision or
sound to do non-invasive remote
monitoring
of all kinds of things so some examples
using drones to fly them over
agricultural fields to collect images
that you then use machine learning to
allow the high density but
low depth image telemetry to
be linked to high density or sorry low
density high depth telemetry so say for
example
sensors that you can deploy every square
mile or something like that
to then interpolate that high dense or
high depth data
to a higher density right so finding
your test
infestations in the field or acidity
conditions that need to be mitigated
with lyme or something like that so in
other words
visual ability to scale monitoring
of systems much more efficiently another
example is deploying
microphones to listen to say a factory
floor
and being able to hear things that are
going wrong because humans in that
environment
have to wear ear protection and whatnot
but if any one of their experts take
their ear protection off
they can just notice by sound that
something is grinding or making a weird
noise over here and this is the ability
to augment existing technologies
non-invasively with with telemetry
gathering systems they're even very
scalable and efficient like drones or
hot air balloons with a camera or
whatever to just
vastly extend our ability to monitor
and detect so that we can go and
mitigate
that's interesting if you wouldn't mind
could i i'll just come back to
satchel's example about the the robotics
as well
that seems like the direction that we
should be going in
and at the moment most self-driving cars
are using
traditional control modules they might
be using ordinary differential equations
or something
you'd know far more about this than me
but at the moment
the the perception models use deep
learning
and one of the real challenges i think
with reinforcement learning is probably
first of all the sample efficiency
problem
and which i think can be solved to some
extent with model-based reinforcement
learning but the second problem of
course is that
they just don't generalize very well so
essentially they're memorization
machines and
you couldn't possibly train it in every
possible situation
and then probably the third problem is
that these machines are black boxes and
in a very
sort of highly sensitive scenario as in
lives are at risk
we really need to understand their
behavior so do those three things
preclude
reinforcement learning from being
appropriate for self-driving cars
i don't know it should not be so you
yourself said that each of those
problems
can itself be solved like at least the
theory of reinforcement learning does
say that with function approximation it
is
generalizable and it's both
generalizable and discriminant
there is nothing preventing it from
underlying theory to say that it is not
possible
it's just that we probably haven't
reached that state but you're absolutely
not sample efficient there are many
different problems or real world things
are not
possible to bring into simulation
i don't know i'm not doing research in
reinforcement learning so i don't have a
very great idea of
absolute recent cutting edge what's
happening but einstein's
it's all crap it's all smoke and mirrors
exactly sorry i'm just hoping that maybe
someday
at least theoretically it sounds all
possible
so we'll be able to get there but it's
my hope
i'm not sure whether it can be done or
not as far as i know theory it doesn't
look like it should not be possible
it's yeah and it's still with again with
this like theoretical guarantees or
explainability understandability so if
you have two
two systems for to to operate like fix
your
i don't know operate on your liver or
something would you or your self-driving
car would you choose the system that you
can fully understand
but or the system that you can't
understand but makes only 10
of the mistakes say you could look at
all the statistics of the last 10 year
and you could accurately say this system
makes 10 accidents every a million
kilometers
the system i don't understand but it
only
makes one accident every so and i'm not
sure anyone would choose the 10
accidents just because they can they can
lay there in their accident be like this
is clearly because the brakes failed
like it's it seems
i'm not sure but but the thing is though
if you took the policy for a
self-driving car and as
chalet said the other week if you deploy
it in japan it won't work
whereas if you drive a car in japan it
will work
so it might appear that it's not made
any mistakes but that's only because
in this domain where we have quite
controlled statistical
we've got a controlled environment it
hasn't yet seen anything
that it didn't encounter during training
i i agree but yeah it's a bit of a
different situation than what what i
proposed i was just
trying to yeah saying this that this
understandability might be a bit
overrated
at some point i'm not saying it's
worthless it's just that it's it's not
the end-all
end-all of of things i feel
what is relevant to the end user is
going to be is this going to fulfill my
my wishes and my goals and is going to
help me
and let's be honest people don't
understand their technology
right now like they have no idea how
their phone work not even
us have any idea how our phones work
right
like just on that i agree with you so
there's three things sample efficiency
generalization and understandability
the understandability one i'm completely
on on the same page as you i don't think
we should understand all technology
we should test it test it
somewhere i think somewhere in here is
an interesting analogy
so airplanes right people have this kind
of fear of
flying in airplanes or i think it's
generally accepted that
at least in the u.s let's say on average
a person is probably more afraid of
flying than they are
driving their car even though they're
much more likely to be
harmed or killed driving their car per
mile and i think
some of that is attributed to the lack
of control right if i'm driving a car i
feel like i'm
in some sense autonomous i have control
whereas i'm putting my life in the hands
of a pilot
who i don't know i've only seen them
through a little narrow door or
something like that and
a very complex systems and and when they
fail it's
over it's catastrophic right there's
almost zero chance of kind of survival
and there's a connection here between
that and technology that i can
understand
and therefore i can in my mind simulate
another
agent like myself in that situation and
i can feel comfortable with the choices
they're gonna make
and whatnot versus this machine that i'm
not sure who it is
what it is what it's doing and so
there's a connection there and the other
thing i'm wondering is
what work has been done on the
evolutionary basis
of this this intuition that people have
right or this feeling because it may not
be without
without value if you think about suppose
you have a population of individuals
and they're very apt to just put their
trust in in
one entity to provide the solution for
them
and they don't really they don't care if
they understand it and they don't apply
their own
evaluation or thought process to it i
think it's very easy for a single entity
to go haywire and lead the entire
population off the cliff
so we probably have built in this innate
desire to
understand and re-evaluate and reassess
on our own as agents
to provide some kind of mitigation for
this tail risk of everyone following
something that goes terribly wrong
yeah like i agree
yeah i would choose the one that had ten
percent less i don't
actually i know enough about machines
and whatever to if it's ten percent
if it's one tenth as many surgical items
left in my gut or something like that
i'm i'm definitely going to take the the
one that performs better
statistically i was saying i have a
simple heuristics i don't understand
humans very well or fully
i mean it's the same with the machine so
what i mean i'm still
living and taking decisions all the time
so what's the reference
yeah that's we we need to keep in mind
the alternatives like with the algo
shambles what was the alternative
that we just let some people in a closed
room who we don't know and we have no
idea what they're up to make the
decision
if if the alternative to a self-driving
car is like a brand new
uh driver that has a poor record which i
don't
you know so we have to keep in mind
there's there's no free lunch
there's no silver bullets what's the
alternative and and do a rational
comparison of the two
this might be quite a good segue
actually because sachin was just saying
uh
about the dichotomy between
understanding machines and understanding
people in meat space
you wrote a couple of articles actually
and one was called how to be an
exceptional software engineer and the
second one was how to be an exceptional
tech lead so why don't you give us the
elevator pitch
uh for how to be an exceptional software
engineer
well they were that it's that what
you're saying dude
just to make sure you can choose you you
can did you talk yeah
i i was an article just to make sure
that it's like
summarizing what i learned and a lot of
we've i work with a lot of
junior people who come into microsoft
just to make them understand
what does it take to become a good
software engineer there are a few things
like one of the first things which i
said is
learn a functional language most of us
come from an object oriented and we take
in school and then we keep learning just
doing that especially microsoft we do
most of the time c
sharp just by doing another functional
language
will open your eyes to new ways of
thinking and then it will make you a
better c-sharp programmer
which is in your uh you know your
birthday
and so on i think it summarizes what i
think i have learned
i write these kind of articles because
you never know
the next day you're not alive so you
must always capture what you have
learned till now
in some place for posterity somebody
might find useful
that's why i tend to write these summary
articles maybe
next year i turn 40. so when i turn 40 i
have this
40 lessons in 40 years like
what if i never see 41 so i'm like i've
listed what i think was good for my life
and what i have learned or something
maybe somebody would find it useful
so that's the main reason i i put my
thoughts in there
so you have to you're externalizing your
intelligence right
is that exactly externalized
intelligence
yeah i i think it's like uh from
epicurean or stoic philosophy like
finitude you should not be afraid of
your
ending of your do not be afraid of your
ending of your life
you just have to prepare for it so it's
like you're ready for your finitude
you don't have to be afraid of it's a
very epicurean
way of writing the article just for
posterity
be prepared that you might not be here
next year
i don't want to sound morose but he's
just one of the philosophies there
yeah every day every day i'm tweaking my
headstone i'm almost
i've almost chosen the perfect wording
for it
put up a straw poll now
i'd be quite interested in also in the
tech tech lead
what you've learned in that respect
because coming from engineering and so
on i think
a lot less people have sort of an
insight
what it means to be to be a tech lead
and
also the most tech leads i think
were themselves just engineers
below reporting to a tech lead at some
point and not necessarily
prepared for that so what is do you have
any anything that
again do you have anything that most
people don't expect
when they first become a tech lead that
you maybe in your experience was like
wet i need to do
this right it's a very good point in
fact i would say that you're right since
most
it's very likely that you become a tech
lead because you were quite a good
engineer and you can see the
architecture you can see things
happening and things like those
and since in an individual contributor
role you're expected to contribute
individually it's very easy for a
technique to get stuck
into solving detailed problems and i
in my article i start with the thing
saying if there was only one thing you
need to learn it's like
the technique needs you need to get
everything done
but you don't have to do everything i
think this is the main place where
as a tech lead you're ultimately
responsible yes
but a lot of people get caught by
thinking that they
also need to do that stuff so there's a
lot of stuff to do
you have to make sure you have to get it
done but you don't have to do it i think
this is the main difference between a
good tech lead
technique which gets stuck into small
narrow places and i say that okay if
you're an engineer
who wants to come in the morning look at
the screen facing the wall
and solve a complex technical problem
don't be a tech lead
you're not the right person for a tech
lead you know don't do it
you have to be the person who's going to
see and how to help other people and
make sure that things are aligned
so it's a very different role and it's
unexpected for good strong individual
contributors to become an effective
tech leader and that's the reason i
wrote that article that was my next
question actually because i know at
microsoft they have this conception that
even as an independent contributor
you can go all the way and i think there
are a couple of examples of
level 69 ics but it's incredibly rare
right and so if you are building out
competencies for the career progression
of a software engineer
clearly at some point it it becomes less
about
software engineering and more about
forced multipliers and being able to
work effectively with others so just so
do you think being
a senior person in a software
engineering organization almost mandates
that it's more about people skills than
software skills
there is no denying the fact that
people skills every problem turned out
to be a
person or a people problem even software
problem turns out to be a person or a
people problem like something
is wrong with the interaction so i do
think it's very important having said
that
technically at least in microsoft is a
role and it's not uh
it's not a title it's not a position so
you can
be a technique for one project because
it gives you good experience and
you are capable of looking at the whole
architecture for this particular case
but in the next one you can just
jump in and spend time in a technical
capacity it it does differ it does
differ from team to team so some teams
which are highly customer facing uh yes
a person or your personal skills and how
to do that
is considered more important but if
you're in some product group i think
technical skills can take you
quite far with respect to to
alignment i i find this to be very
interesting topic
let's say even let's say you have one
team or even if maybe you're a lead for
a couple of teams together how do you
align
that what did you find how do you make
people
work in one direction i know a lot of
companies have like
incentive structure with promotions and
so on
and others maybe try to do it via
personal connection and motivation
and others are just authoritarian
did you find any like best recipe
for making people work on the same thing
that everyone
joins in with their full force that's
again a very good question i think there
are multiple ways to solve it my
personal
is to have i follow i'm in microsoft but
i follow what google does
is like okr so we have i try to set some
objectives
and then we make some key results and
those objectives and key results are
open from one team to the other so
team one team two and team three know
each other's objectives and they reflect
the objectives of the next layer so then
it's easy
it's not only a matter of doing your
objectives is to make sure that your
objectives match up the next layer and
then you have key results to make sure
you
attain your objectives now different
people as i say have different way of
doing it
i find it like transparency opens up
or removes a lot of problems like if you
know what the other team is driving
towards
then it's just easy to align with that
team unfortunately lots of teams just
keep their objectives to themselves and
never share it
with others so i think that's where the
alignment goes out of disalignment and
then you need some person
to make this alignment happen i feel
like if the teams are very transparent
then they are aligned
could i gently challenge on that there
used to be this kind of objective
obsession even in the software
engineering industry i think there was a
guy in the early 80s who kicked all of
this off and
there was this notion that we should be
measuring software engineers by the
number of lines of code that they check
in or test passing and so on and
clearly that was it created a kind of
perverse incentive and everyone gamified
the system and it was
the result was almost antithetical to
better software engineering particularly
on on large ambitious software projects
with a lot of folks in there
and now the entire industry is in in
some sense moved away from it but now
the objectives are more in a meta
process sense so
in terms of how we do our agile project
management methodology and so on so
where do you draw the line there so i'll
tell you effective
activity metrics do not work
but effectiveness metrics do work like
you were saying so
activity matrix is like a to-do list in
the morning and lots of this
is filled with small stuff which is just
to do some activity they are not really
uh providing an end benefit so if you
are setting a
metric it must reflect the
the end thing you're trying to achieve
rather than the activity what i mean to
say is like this
100 lines of code is almost of no
significance but
shipping a feature is so instead of
measuring how many
uh lines of code you're submitting you
can certainly the team can start to
measure
its overall end user feature submitted
of course
you can still challenge that say okay
what about features if they're not
valuable yes they're all true
but you can take this argument n plus
one till the end and try to make
every layer which is not an activity
metric but an
effectiveness metric so that's not
efficient but effective
that's the way to look at it so one is
anyone who's interested in a career in
software engineering
go by the mythical man month by fred
brooks
which was written in 1975 immediately
and read it so this will educate you on
some very
key concepts about what's special about
the software engineering
you know world i did just want to
comment on a couple
so sorry keith you can't just say that
and not give us the elevator pitch
so the man there's so many elevator
pitches in that
one so first of all he he talks a lot
about no silver bullets
to try and drill this in and he gives a
lot of examples of that
he talks about how the id the main
difference between software
okay and and almost every other probably
every other kind of
human endeavor is that you can't force
progress
by parallelizing the development so
suppose i want to dig a ditch
that's a hundred miles long okay and
it's gonna take one guy
a hundred years or something to dig that
i can go hire a hundred people
and get it done in in one year because
they can just work independently on
their little section of ditch and
the world is quite analog in the sense
that if the ditches don't quite line up
like they're 20 feet apart
we can dig some more dirt and correct
that problem quite easily
software is not like that it's very
fragile you can't like
if you're building an airplane and
you're not sure if this bolt needs to be
uh two millimeters thick if that's
enough we'll just make it two and a half
and and you'll be okay you can't do that
with for loop
i'm not sure what the limit is on this
thing maybe let me just
add or subtract a little bit to it and
it should work right that's not how
software works and the debugging process
is very linear so you have to figure out
one problem
and then move on to the next problem
that appears you can't in parallel kind
of work on all the
things that are going wrong with this
particular
bug just doesn't work like that because
of this fragility
and linear nature of debugging if you
just add more and more people to a
project
it actually doesn't accelerate the
development of that software progress
in a project and it can actually impede
it because now you have this sort of
n-squared communication problem that has
to go on where all the people working
have to be aware of some subset of
other people yeah quick interjection
this is similar to what charlay said
about scientific
it's increasing exponentially but the
actual value is quite linear
yeah yeah so that's very related uh kind
of problem because scientific progress
is often linear as well right it's like
somebody figures out something new and
that's added to but there are other
problems in science as well there are a
lot of
if you read uh was a coons work on the
theory of scientific revolution and
whatnot
that ultimately makes the same comment
that science advances by one funeral at
a time
so there's a lot of sociological kind of
problems in science but
anyway mythical man month absolute
awesome read
i do want to just point out a couple
things that i learned yannick managing
software teams in the past so number one
is
you need to have clear written
specifications
so it's not good enough to just verbally
ask somebody to go
do something you need to really have
that in writing sent over in an email
like here's the
the specifications for for what needs to
be done on this piece so that
there's a concrete measure of whether or
not we've done this correctly
and if they come back and haven't done
all of that it
you have to delegate back to them to go
back again and continue the work
until the the specification is met so
just tying in with what
satchen said earlier is that delegation
was the hardest thing for me to learn
and i i liked engineering i like solving
problems i love helping people and so
my innate tendency is to go and try and
solve a problem for somebody
but when you're running a team you've
got to build up their capabilities to
develop and solve the problems
and it's hard it's hard to turn over a
critical
step in a project and not to stress out
about whether or not
it's going to get completed and so
you've got to learn to delegate and the
best advice i ever had on that was a
manager
i said i don't know how to do this like
how do i delegate and he goes okay
just think about what you would do today
and then
figure out who else could do some of
those pieces
instead of you and then write up the
specification and delegate to them
and then the important thing that keeps
that process moving along
smoothly is regular communication you
need to have at least a daily check-in
on how are things going and it's not
because you're trying to micromanage
them and engage their progress it's more
just
can i help you is there some blocker
you've run into that maybe because of
some experience i've had
i can help you with or maybe i know
someone else within the organization
that can help us
solve that problem and that does have
the side effect of kind of
in a good way keeping people a bit on
their toes because now they're motivated
to make progress because they know that
their peers are going to be
reviewing this progress so it's just
kind of a friendly motivation yeah
data scientists would hate that because
they would say you're trusting
their creativity and we we talked about
a divergent search and they should be
treasure hunting and discovering new
things and that's
antithetical to i want you to check in
with me every day and tell me what
you're working on
i'm gonna tell you the secret the reason
why and i've hated that in the past too
the reason why people hate that is that
we're not sure
we're doing the right thing we're not
sure we're doing everybody thinks their
code
sucks just get over it i my code does
suck
if you come and tell me dude this code
you wrote sucks i'm gonna say
i get it i'm sorry like i didn't put
enough time into that
here let's try to make it better so
they're worried that
one of their peers is going to look at
their neural network or how they tweaked
resnet or something
and be like what are you some kind of
idiot why did you
put this dropout layer in there and and
look you've compressed this dimension
down by a factor of two that's dumb
like we're all worried that somebody's
gonna have some negative feedback
we're all in the same boat okay we're
all
just get over that accept this kind of
communication it'll keep you on your
toes in a good way
and keep driving you towards forward
progress
anyway i've actually written up a lot of
this back in 2009 and some
post in a old usenet forum i'll dredge
up the link and
and send it to you in case it's helpful
and i apologize gentlemen i have a hard
stop right now so i'm actually going to
have to to drop off the call but
it's been a pleasure honestly thank you
it's great cheers bye-bye
okay sachin final thoughts thank you for
having me it was fun
great discussion starting with
programming languages if nothing else
and going on too many different things i
have to say you're like why do you have
a green screen at the back
oh i yeah that's just where i keep it
yeah okay i thought putting green screen
behind you on the internet is considered
like a whoa a dangerous thing to do
because somebody can now extract it and
put you somewhere
else where you don't want to be maybe
that's maybe that's the
that's the goal just okay yeah i was
curious
are you calling for painting it's like a
bait video
it's all right but thank you oh it was
nice to talk to you guys
and now that you've said that section uh
that you've just you've inspired me to
make one of those videos
so you can expect it to be super imposed
on on the start of this
anyway uh sachin it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for joining
us and
i i really appreciate it yeah
just for me to get to pick the brains of
people actually working in the field
is just incredibly valuable and i think
for a lot of people
to hear from you yeah thanks great i'm
glad
we could do this thank you thank you
amazing take care guys
cheers bye